we wanted security we wanted safety  there was no Insurrection and there  wasn't going to be an Insurrection it  was made up by these sick people I've  never seen Trump look like this behave  like this talk like this Nancy Pelosi  and the D.C mayor refused if they'd  listened to me my recommendation none of  this would have happened now remember  we've learned since first Trump kept  saying I wanted 10 to 20 000 troops to  protect the capital and Nancy Pelosi  turned him down and what we realized was  Nancy Pelosi didn't turn anything down  Trump didn't request 10 to 20 000 troops  to protect the capital it's actually  even sicker we've now learned Trump  wanted 10 000 troops to protect him on  January 6th him not to protect the  capital to protect him it's insane that  that's actually the truth of the matter